can talk now to the General Secretary of
the Royal College of Nursing Pat Cullen
great to have you on the show this
morning I'm sure this is going to be the
number one priority for so many of our
viewers uh this morning
nurses from your union are shortly going
to be walking out what is the impact of
that strike going to be
well clearly there will be an impact of
course there will be
um but it's an impact that can be
stopped by this government if they would
get around the table again and start to
talk to me about the hundreds of
thousands of nurses that participated in
this ballot but leaving that aside I
want to just correct one thing that was
said by Mark Harper this morning around
the Royal College of Nursing not putting
in place National exemptions to make
sure that our patients are continued to
be treated safely during this period of
strike that's not true we have put
National exemptions in place and our
nurses as we have I've said time and
time again will never leave their
patients unsafe or create more risk
that's already in the system at this
point in time can we just clear this up
yes because I'm confused I'm honest I'm
totally confused about what exemptions
are in place and what aren't yes
previous strikes there have been
exemptions for emergency care right a e
cancer maternity and so on my
understanding was that some hospitals
will get exemptions Great Ormond Street
for example who have raised concerns
about Staffing levels but but not all so
what is the truth what's going on there
are National exemptions in place for a
range of services for emergency
departments for intensive care units for
neonatal units Pediatric Intensive Care
units those really acute urgent Services
we have put National exemptions in place
we've worked tirelessly with NHS England
in fact it was the Royal College of
Nursing contacted NHS England to ask for
a process to be put in place so that we
could make sure that this strike was
safe for our patients because that's not
what I thought right so what's going on
though has it changed or
look we issued our notices for 10 days
ago as I said we contacted NHS England
to work um with them and alongside them
to put a process in place with that
process in place and those National
exemptions have been granted right up
until last night we were working on
those and right throughout the period of
strike we will continue to have an
incident room within the Royal College
of Nursing headed up by a very Senior
Chief nurse that will ensure that any
exemptions that are requested during
that time are considered carefully and
on the clinical basis that that they
deserve are you confident then that
lives won't be put a risk by this strike
well you'll heard me say time and time
again why are nurses going on strike
they're going on strike because patients
lives are being put at risk every single
day and why because we have tens of
thousands of vacant nursing posts so I
want to say something else to some of
the general managers that have toured
the studio speaking over today and other
days and what I would say to them is
think carefully about what they are
saying and none of those people I
believe have walked in the shoes of our
nursing staff and I would say to them as
well it's interesting that they've come
today to talk about the risk that's
posed as a result of our nurses taking
strike action for the very reason that
I've said because of the crisis within
the Health Service and I would ask them
for those other 364 days of the year
speak up for their nursing staff tell
what the risk is that they are carrying
every single day and I would also ask
for those general managers how many of
them have ever walked in the shoes of
our nursing staff off so instead of
coming out today against those nursing
staff come alongside them and don't try
to silence them you're talking about
general managers of hospitals yes I am
so you think you think that actually
they don't really understand what some
of their
hard-working nurses are doing well is
there a bit of a split I think I think
there has to be when you hear some of
the comments this morning from the chief
executive of NHS employers for example
talking about the risk that's posed on
the day of a strike and would ask him to
step back and think why have nurses
taken this action after 106 years
because of the risk that they are
carrying every single day on behalf of
their patients so whilst the day of a
strike is important to the likes of the
NHS chief executive NHS employers chief
executive those other 364 days when the
burden of that risk is carried by our
nursing staff should also be important
and walk in the shoes of those nurses
and see what it's like look I can see
your passion right about the the service
that you represent
just put until one side though because
the question was about patient safety on
the strike days do you accept that
nurses going on strike does put patients
at risk
I accept that on days of strike that
services do not have the same level of
nursing staff and what they would have
on other days but again Sophie I go back
to those other 300 I understand this I
understand that point on that but I'm
just asking specifically it's inspirable
it really is inseparable why have our
nursing staff been pushed to the brink
to take this action and lose another
day's pay on a day of a bank holiday
when actually they would get a few extra
points and they're willing to take to
take that they take to take that on
behalf of their patients and why because
they cannot continue on with the level
of risk that they're carrying it's those
people that sit at the bedside of the
patient and know that when they leave
they've left care undone simply because
there's not enough hours on the day and
these are selfless people they're
standing up for their patients what I'd
ask is for NHS employers and this
government to get behind them and I
think if we listen to the voice of
nursing we'll do the best thing for the
NHS and we'll certainly do the best
thing for those nurses now the
government's offered 500 paydale
Unison have accepted it G and B have
accepted it why should the RCM be
different
well I believe that nursing is different
because nursing is the only profession
that stays alongside their patient 365
days a year 24 hours a day and they
believe that the short-term money that
was put into their pockets as a result
of this offer a non-consolidated it's
referred to it gives them money now but
it's taken back out at the end of the
year so what they were saying is it
might it might put a few points in my
pocket as an individual but it does
nothing to address the Recruitment and
Retention crisis that we've got of
nursing so again it's back to that
selflessness bit about them not being
greedy as an individual but they're
wanting to address the long-term
problems within the Health Service what
I can't work out
is that you recommended the steel to
your members right
so you must have thought it was a decent
deal well
our ruling Council carefully considered
it along with myself and when you look
at the total package there were elements
of that package where actually
um worth worth putting to our members
and asking our members to consider
thought it was that bad you said if you
recommended it well look the money the
money was never going to actually be
what our nurses would have accepted it's
it's a it's hard why did you recommend
it below inflation because and I will
explain
there were issues there that we we
actually felt were worth looking at
around safer Staffing policy positions
which we feel would leave us in a better
position to have safer Staffing
legislation put in place and again
that's about nurses striking for the
Health Service and for their patients
not them as individuals and the other
element which has got a little bit
controversial with the other unions but
there's there's a rationale for this and
that is that we need to look at the pay
structure that Awards nursing staff and
why do we need to do that because the
current pay structure does not work for
nursing otherwise we wouldn't have the
retention and recruitment problems we've
got 62 percent of our nursing Workforce
sits in the lowest band within agenda
for Change and they don't enjoy some of
the other terms and conditions within
agenda for change that some of the other
professions do now this is not about
pitting ourselves against other
professional groups it's about asking
for nurses to be treated the same and
alongside those other professional
groups I've got to ask do you endorsed a
deal that ended up being rejected by
your members are you now feeling that
you have to slightly overcompensate kind
of shore up your own position in the
union absolutely not I am in an absolute
privileged position to be able to
represent hundreds of thousands of
nursing staff I actually believe in them
it's privilege to represent them they
have said loud and clear this deal is
not good enough it will not address the
issues that we're trying to address
within the Health Service and for me
it's not historic it is not a historic
payday in relation to the historic
action that they have taken I've heard
it described as fair and reasonable
there are fair things within the deal
but it doesn't go far enough and that's
why we need to get around the table
again and to start to address these
issues now on Tuesday of course the
health unions are meeting with ministers
to see if a majority of NHS workers
except the five percent deal and because
the biggest unions are backed at Unison
GMB it's pretty likely it's going to go
through so you nurses will get the five
percent pay rise if that happens what
will you do then will you take the money
and still go on strike we'll still
encourage the Secretary of State to get
around the table with the Royal College
of Nursing if you look at the strike
action that has taken place today it has
been taken by nurses and the Royal
College of Nursing and it has been taken
by those nurses those hundreds of
thousands of nurses voted to take strike
action after 106 years so we can't
ignore the voice of those people and if
he continues to do that and this
government does we will be rebalancing
our members come the mid-may close a mid
mid June and that means that we could
Fair strike action right up until
Christmas period but again I would urge
the Secretary of State Steve Barkley and
this government particularly the Prime
Minister don't push nurses to that
position because there's no there's no
win for patients out of this and it's
wrong to do this for for nursing staff
okay thank you very much indeed Pat
calendar of the RCN explaining her
position thank you very much thank you
yesterday this morning